You know who else is happy,
living in one of your relationships?
Everybody, talking about you and Aubrey Plaza.
Oh boy.
(audience applauds)
I mean, this is click bait headlines around the world.
You premiered your movie, "Spin Me Round"
at South By Southwest,-
Yes.
You and Aubrey have a kissing scene,
make out scene, something,
and it is literally all the rage.
People are flipping out about it.
I have to say that I took a little break
from doing press for a minute, I was working
and COVID was happening.
Quarantining.
I hadn't been doing,
you know, you get in a groove where you're doing interviews
and you're really good at it?
And I forgot about click bait as a thing.
And just was like, "Yeah, make out scene?
It was great, it was my favorite night on set."
Like you say, these things-
Totally.
Delicious, hyperbolic isms
Not realizing (giggles)
that become click bait headlines.
Yes and also, because as we shot so much
other stuff that night,
that doesn't get included in the article
where I was like, "It was my favorite night of shooting.
We shot a scene in a dance club.
We shot a scene where Aubrey steals a Vespa."
They're like, "Who cares?"
It was the best night of my life.
"How was the make out?"
Well then they're just like,
(audience applauds)
"They made out.
It was the best night of my life."
And I'm like, I gotta text Aubrey and be like,
"Sorry, I..."
Or do you need to text Dave and say
(laughs) He's fine with it.
And like, then I'm like, all right, okay
if you're kissing Dave Franco on set
or you're kissing Aubrey Plaza,
you know, who you having more fun with?
Who's more comfortable?
(audience applauds)
(Alison laughs)
What are you talking to Aubrey about?
What are you talking to Dave about?
In fairness, you know, "Spin Me Round"
is a movie that I wrote with my writing partner, Jeff Baena.
This is our second film that we've written
and produced together.
But it's my fourth film that I've done with Jeff
and Jeff is Aubrey's husband.
I love that you guys make films,
that you collaborate,
that you have these deep rooted friendships
that you also create and collaborate with.
You're just putting goodness out into the world.
Both of you, amazing couples, just keep doing it,
'cause it's so good. (applauds)
It's so good.
Thank you, thank you.
(audience applauds)
It's so fun for all of us.
Okay, your current project, "Roar",
now it's like Nicole Kidman and you
and people are really talking about this.
It's highly anticipated.
Yes.
People are freaking out,
critical acclaim already.
(Alison chuckles)
"Roar", I watched your episode last night.
Great.
And tell us about
why everybody's talking about this show.
Yes, well, it's such a cool concept.
It was created by the two women
that also created "Glow",
Liz Flahive and Carly Mensch.
And it's based off a book of short stories
which are these feminist fables.
So it's an anthology series,
it's eight different episodes
and each episode stars a different woman,
is directed by a woman, written by a woman.
They are these feminist powerhouse stories,
but they're told with some magical surrealism,
some dark comedy.
They all have a sense of humor to them.
Yeah, I like how deep they can go
without being heavy and dark.
I love it.
And I think it is worth all the hype
and I can't wait for people to see it.
(bright music)